[Musique]
monsieur aux rouches on vous a testé
positif pour le vih
nous estimons qu'il vous reste trente
jours à vivre y a rien sur cette terre
qui puisse tuer ron woodroof en 30 jours
[Musique]
de nouveaux médicaments sont disponibles
pour être testés et dans ce [ __ ]
d'hôpital j'en ai besoin
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça sur une
route vous allez vous comme ça ils ont
bon médoc au mexique
c'est mieux que ce qu'on a ici aux
states et on peut pas les acheter aux
etats-unis non approuvés pour y faire
fortune avec ça nous importer des
médicaments illégaux pour défendre pas
illégaux dans à prouver c'est tout
je te cherche partout les qui les
écoutent princesse à moins que tu es
plus d'argent nouveaux clients chez
occupée tu mérites panneaux pognon
mios dallas buyer's clad traiter ces
patients se traite au même je vends pas
de la drogue font des adhésions au club
[Musique]
nous faut du nouveau matos fois des cas
mr dame la chine et israël
on peut s'entendre avec eux pourquoi
mais la chouette resto une belle femme
je me sens redire
j'ai eu droit où vous n'êtes qu'un
vulgaire trafiquant de drogue
[Musique]
je n'ai qu'une fille
non mais longuet
[Musique]